Raz Abramov, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you?
Thank you for having me.
All is well. How are you?
Everything is great.
It's so late in Tel Aviv right now.
Thank you for being here at this hour.
I'm really excited for this talk
and to chat with you
and to learn about your journey
both as an entrepreneur, as a VP R&D.
Transitioning to product from VP R&D.
And talking about everything.
From helping run the company
from bootstrap,
to moving between different customers
around the world.
I can't wait to learn as much as I can
over those 20 minutes.
But Raz, I'd like to start off.
Tell me a little bit about your journey.
How did you get started?
How how did you end up
VP R&D at EverCompliant?
It's a long journey indeed.
But that's only the beginning.
I've been a technologist
from a young age.
Ever since I could pick up a keyboard,
[--]
I started [--]
How early was that would you say?
Seventh grade.
I think my dad,
who's also a developer,
he's still until today,
pushed C++ book to my life, and said,
"Start reading."
So, I started reading.
So, basically, while a lot of people
were reading Harry Potter at 12.
You were reading a book on C++?
Yes. Something like that.
Okay. Good.
Just clarifying for everybody.
Then, throughout high school
my [--]
and then I joined the army to 8200 units
and Technology Center
where I did military service,
also did some training.
I guided the course that I've been to,
the junior soldier.
That was a lot of fun.
And after five years, I got on the list
and then I started freelancing, actually.
I want to taste
a little bit of everything.
So, that everything from software,
to chip designs, to mobile apps.
I helped a lot of people
making their dreams come true.
And then I decided
that I want to follow my own.
How long did you do freelancing for?
Roughly three years.
So, when we started EverCompliant,
my company,
I still bootstrapped.
So, I still did a little bit
of freelancing at first.
But then transitioned to full time
once we started to head off.
Now, I do want to delay
on this comment that you made.
You said something about helping others
make their dreams come true.
Right?
Elaborate a little bit about that.
Because it's an interesting way
of phrasing what you were doing
as a freelancer
and you chose to do it for three years
to perhaps gain perspective.
But what does that mean to you
that you are helping others
achieve their dreams
or making them come true?
So, as I was working
in fact finding clients
is less of probably when you have
the community that we have
in the Israeli military.
So, I worked towards
a lot of entrepreneurs
that have the different challenges
in different areas.
Where they have the vision,
they have the idea,
the great concept of
how they want to see their company.
And they need some guidance
in the technology area.
So, just to someone
that can tie it all together
and show them that  forward.
And that was a great pleasure for me
to work with them on these areas on.
Really, to see the spark in their eyes
when they see the finished product.
So, just to clarify.
you would come in and help these
entrepreneurs, founders, etc,
or other technology teams,
and you would come and help them
with your skill sets.
Come in, help them with the product,
bring it to fruition,
bring their vision on the computer.
And then, they would enjoy this product.
And then something within you said,
"Okay. I want to do this myself."
"I want to create my own company."
Exactly.
Okay. So, we're there now.
Tell me a little bit about EverCompliant.
So, we started in the garage.
Two coders and the CEO,
just looking for the [--] for customers.
We actually pivoted a few times,
polishing the idea.
We started the bootstrap completely
[--]
until we saw [--]
And I think that the first major milestone
was around a funding
which we raised from Cardinal Ventures,
[--]
And that happened after we landed
our first regular client [--]
[--] Yeah.
So, we've been working with them
on the products for about a year.
And as we raised a round A,
we saw that their problem
is really an international problem.
Global problem.
And they had a problem with merchants
passing the illegal activity through them
without them knowing.
That they were working with the company
they thought was selling shoes
out of [--].
And it turns out that they
have been hiding illegal activity.
I won't mention the specifics because,
Yeah. [--] Right.
But, yes. So, we develop technology
to help them see that.
Help them gain visibility
into those areas,
mainly in the e-commerce space.
And we saw that this problem was global.
So, we took our luggage
and went to Mexico and said,
"Hi. We notice a problem."
"And can we help you solve it?"
They said,
"You arrived at the right time."
"This is the problem."
"We've known about it."
"We're working on the definite solution."
So, hold on, hold on, Raz.
I want to paint the picture.
You have two coders and a CEO
out of the garage, bootstrapped,
just raised your series A.
And you're knocking on the door
of MasterCard and you're saying,
"Hey, we have this technology."
"Is this relevant?"
And they're saying,
"Yes, it's very relevant."
Right?
Actually, that meeting is a funny story.
We arrived at the meeting,
after meeting with
a potential partner in Atlanta.
Now, we plan to have the flight
in the previous day
to arrive to New York [--].
But it was snowed in
and the airports are closed.
It weren't the first time
that the snow hit Atlanta.
And so,we drove all night in shifts
until we arrived at the meeting on time.
And the rest is history.
Wow. Wow.
Okay. So, I mean, that literally
is like an entrepreneur movie.
You get in the car and driving all night.
Okay. So, you begin, I guess,
working with MasterCard and helping.
So, just dumb it down for me.
What is EverCompliant?
And how do you actually help
those that are doing online transactions?
Because I'm very familiar
with the complexity of compliance.
Obviously, I'm coming also
from the insurance space now at Hippo.
So, I understand compliance a little bit,
but not nearly enough
to really understand what you're doing.
So, our specialty is to find connections
between online activities
It's usually around commerce.
What we found is that, today,
it's very easy to set up
an online merchant.
Almost easy.
It takes about 10 minutes.
An access to your
favorite website building your platform.
And then you have a website ready to go
and you can start transacting.
And that acceleration
of e-merchants popping up,
has create a smoke screen
where you can hide illegal activity
without people detecting it.
And that's what we're doing
at EverCompliant.
We mop out all of the online activity.
Online commerce activity.
And by extracting data
from each and every website,
about what the website is doing.
And who are the owners of the websites.
Who registered domain,
or the company behind it.
And other details.
We're able to connect
these activities together.
So, when we approached our customers
that were banks and service providers
anyone who wants it, and merchants,
we can get their promotion portfolio
and connect to the seemingly
legitimate merchants [--].
So, give me a little bit of background
about this market.
Because it sounds like this is a problem
that is especially relevant today.
Maybe less so, 15 or 20 years ago
when building online presence
and gaining credibility
wasn't as democratized as it is today.
Why aren't there so many others
working the space?
Or, maybe there are.
I mean, because it sounds like
this is one of the most relevant things
in today's age, especially as
practically all of our shopping
is done online.
And covid is just accelerating e-commerce,
I'm sure, like crazy.
So, there are competitors in that area.
I have the utmost respect for them.
And we love a good competition.
And when we approach the market, we saw
it was a while ago,
we saw that problem
was ramping up [--].
I can see the numbers of merchants
rising up year after year.
And there was no solution in sight.
And then we decided to build our platform.
And yeah, as the area grew,
our market grew,
and the company grew as well.
So, how do you then,
as one of the founders, and as VP R&D
and soon we'll talk about
the transition to product.
How do you think,
or how much weight do you give
to the congestion of the space?
And how your other competitors
are approaching this?
Because, if there are other competitors
that are direct competitors,
I'm guessing right now
as you're in the hypergrowth stage
and you're trying to gain credibility
and market share,
what are some of the key considerations
that you're bringing to the table?
So, as an Israeli company,
we started from technology.
Of course.
But our competitors actually started
from different business aspects.
So, either from business analysts,
we built an online database
and [--] to customers.
Or different varieties of that area.
And when we approached with the technology
the solution really make things
much better for our customers.
So, in that aspect,
we always try to maintain
that technological edge
and think up the next thing
where the market is going to.
So, we can stay ahead of the curve.
And in that aspect,
when you're building companies,
then you start a path to
heavily invested in R&D
all throughout your lifecycle.
And I'm sure Hippo
still dedicating a lot of resources.
Doubling down. Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, it's something that's important
to [--],
especially when there's always pressure
to put more in marketing and sales.
Just being at the bottom line.
[--] our numbers.
But at the end of the day,
you've built up technology.
[--]
I love it. Okay.
So, again, going back
to three guys in a garage.
Two coders and a CEO,
you're approaching MasterCard
and all of a sudden
you have this huge client.
And this is after, you're also,
your main experience
as a freelance engineer
is to help small teams
bring their products to fruition.
How is this transition of going from,
some Israeli customers for EverCompliant,
all of a sudden, seeing MasterCard,
and working with one of the biggest
online transaction companies?
Give me a little bit of taste
as to what that's like.
So, when you're working with MasterCard,
you have a lot of,
they present you the market list.
They sent us over
to different global companies
and that we tested our product
real time with them.
And they saw the benefits
and they became
our first global customers.
And that process is really
it brings the company
to a different level of maturity.
Because when you look for productivity,
it's very nice, very clean.
The back up position is very crisp
and that's what we're working on.
But once you bring on enterprise customers
and you start [--].
There are a ton of other
operational compliance,
legal demands to meet.
Very long the procurement processes.
Things that the company has to adjust.
And, so, we had some money in the bank,
so we were able to round that up.
But something
that you have to take into account
when you start a B2B enterprise.
Were there any things that were completely
mind blowing or very surprising
in this process as you're maturing
the company very quickly?
Because I'm guessing,
from the moment that you're signing
with MasterCard,
pretty much it's like go time.
You have to reach that maturity
very quickly, right?
Yeah. It's been a meeting after meeting.
And long requirements
are showing up on our doorstep.
And we have to ramp up
our new team very quickly.
We have to ramp up legal compliance.
We have to do standardization efforts.
And again, as you're building
your technology,
you're still a young company,
it's a huge a task to take.
Of course.
And so, talk to me a little bit
about this transition
that you're doing now.
So, VP R&D for EverCompliant.
You started as a founder and VP R&D
and you continued until now.
And you mentioned that you're making
this very interesting transition
to running the product.
Yeah.
So, that all started
about two years ago.
So, as a younger founder,
you're doing pretty much
a little bit of everything.
Right.
So, I thought that
there was a place for me
to take really take the product
and the company forward.
And to lead in that area.
And that it's also been
very interesting for me personally.
And it seemed like something
that the company will benefit from.
So then, we started looking for [--]
took us about a year,
to find someone who is suitable
and [--]
obviously, with the company.
And last year, last August actually,
I started running the part.
And I have to say that
being technology and founder
and products is,
there had a lot of overlap between them.
Especially in a young company.
When you build a technology,
you always have to have a product mindset
to understand what's replicable
and what's not.
What's to build and not to build.
When to say, "no".
It's difficult for enterprise to say "no".
But it's something that
you have to be always take into account
and [--]
and to ramp up,
first of all, myself and product.
Because I haven't had any
formal training before.
[--]
and [--]
has been amazing for me.
But how do you go to an existing company
that you're a part of,
and all of a sudden
assume the role of running the product
without prior knowledge
of running products for companies?
Because essentially,
you're taking on the responsibility
of now building something
that needs to scale
and needs to service the market.
And I'm guessing
that one of the main motivations now
of EverCompliant
is to start gaining market share
and gaining market dominance.
And a lot of it is on your shoulders now
because you're running the product.
So, how do you quickly catch up
to that skill set?
So, for me, it's been a few parts.
First of all, I'm fortunate to know
a lot of very talented people
who are product managers.
And I've met with them,
learned from them,
and asked a lot of questions.
[--]
And I learned a lot that way.
And I also had a chance to work
alongside top managers,
amazing top managers,
I worked with a lot of them.
And last but not least,
I've also dedicate lot of time to read
almost every book in existence on product
to really formalize the training.
And to ramp up my knowledge around that.
And I'm still learning a lot every day.
So, it's never ending story.
I'm sure. I'm sure.
What are the biggest challenges
that you and your co-founders have faced
over the past few years
in your EverCompliant journey?
It could be the bootstrapping part,
the fundraising part,
or the hiring part.
What were some of the things
that you faced that were like,
wow, this is a huge challenge
and I'm really excited to tackle it.
So, there are a lot of
different challenges over there,
I have to say.
But I think the main challenge we had
is going from local to global.
So, from Israel to the United States,
to everywhere else in the world.
And different geographies
have different regulations and mindsets
at different procurement policy.
And to learn to take all that in
to really build a company around this.
It's been an amazing journey.
I love it.
And any advice that you would give
to other young entrepreneurs
who are perhaps
just starting their journey?
Maybe they're finishing the same course
that you and I did.
And now they're transitioning out
to the real world and they're considering
starting out a company from their garage.
But as you both of us know,
it's a weird experience
going out from the IDF's bubble
to the real world
and doing different technology, obviously.
So, first of all,
I'll say what I always say to my employees
when they ask that one day
they want to open the startup
why they should do it or not,
I always say, "Do it."
And if you do that,
I will help you anywhere anyway I can.
I think it's an amazing experience.
So, anybody watching this,
if anybody needs advice,
Raz Abramov is here.
Absolutely.
My door and Facebook are always open.
I love it.
Okay. So now,
comes the most important question.
Why did you do it?
So, I understand why you transitioned
from freelance and you said,
Okay. I'm helping others
achieve their dreams.
What I'm trying to understand also
is why you chose to go in
and start a company?
Because you didn't choose to go
and work at a corporate.
Or experience running engineering
at other companies and then products.
You said, "I'm ready to go
and start my own business."
And that's an interesting
transition to me.
So, talk to me a little bit about
why you chose to do it
and what really gets you up every morning.
So, actually, it was a decision I made
when I was very young.
I was about 17, I think.
I saw the great stories
of the startups of the day.
And I wanted my own story to be written.
So, that's my main driver here.
And that's still driving me today.
So, I want to write that story.
I want to write that big story
that young people look up to and say,
"I want to be that person one day."
And how do you do that then?
So, does that mean that EverCompliant
needs to reach substantial heights?
Does it mean that you need
to be seen as somebody
who is like a mentor to others?
How do you get to the point
where you're writing that story?
So, first of all,
there's no "I" in company.
So, EverCompliant it's like a baby for me.
I've seen it from an infancy.
And I want to see it
reach as high as possible.
And as long as I'm breathing,
I will always strive
to move that company forward.
And yeah, I think that's it.
I love it
Raz, I want to thank you again
for your generosity in your time.
It sounds like an incredible journey.
I'm going to wait for the movie
about the meeting with MasterCard
and driving all night.
But before we leave,
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Whatever it takes.
I love it.
Raz, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
And I look forward to sharing this
with the world.
Thank you.